Louie waterson here at attic question,
how would you suggest someone who's a
jack of all trades and master of none
conduct themselves while you're
probably high in openness,
high in creativity.
And one of the dangers
of being high creativity,
especially if you're
also high in neuroticism,
is that it's hard for creative people
to catalyze and identity because they're
basically pan like,
you know,
like Peter Pan or like,
or like Pan,
which means everything that God of the
forest is the god of everything to some
degree.
And the problem with being everything
is that you're also nothing at the same
time because you'd never specialize.
And so I would say that if you're,
I think that being a jack of all
trades is pretty damn useful.
But I would also say that it's really
necessary to buckle down and find one
primary mode of discipline
and Jack or Louie,
if you can't figure
out what you should do,
then guess just pick something that
you think that you could hit hard and
concentrate on.
You don't have to be perfect at it.
You don't even have to get it right,
but pick something rather than nothing
or pick something rather than all things.
And then set yourself to
master that because you know,
you need to have a,
a,
um,
a discipline,
a primary discipline.
It's absolutely necessary
to succeed in life.
Now,
once you have a primary discipline,
then you can branch out and,
and become a multiplicity in your
disciplined approach and then you're
absolutely bloody unstoppable.
But you really need that
initial disciplinary routine.
You know,
this is something neat you knew up,
knew very well.
Um,
he said,
for example,
I just wrote about this today,
that um,
it was the long unfreedom of the,
of Europe's subjugation to the dogmatic
structures of the Catholic Church that
ennobled the European mind and gave it
the capacity to widely range that it
eventually developed,
but it was that initial subjugation,
not initial voluntary slavery that
produced the discipline that produced the
spirit that can then go
out and do other things.
And it's really,
really useful to subjugate yourself
something to something voluntarily.
You know,
I think that's partly why it's useful to
practice a religious faith because you
subject yourself to a
disciplinary structure that way.
And you might think,
well that's all oppressed
if in all of that.
And of course that's true,
but it also makes you disciplined.
And once you're disciplined,
like you're,
you're like a sharpened sword man,
like a well tempered blade.
And then you can go out there
and operate in the world.
So,
and if you haven't found your passion,
then I would say,
well,
don't wait around until you find the damn
thing because you may never find it is
pick something and focus on it.
You know?
And if you move strongly and forthrightly
towards it for a number of months at
least,
or even a number of years,
and then you find,
well that wasn't the thing for you,
it isn't going to be a waste to anyways.
Because most of the time the
pursuit of any discipline,
knowledge pays off,
even if it doesn't pay off in the
way that you initially expect.